قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه رغم الثمن الباهظ الذي تتكبده
اسرائيل خلال الحرب الدائره في غزه انها
ستواصل القتال حتى النهايه وجدد نتنياهو
في مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه قوله
ان اسرائيل لن توقف الحرب قبل تحقيق
اهدافها ندفع ثمنا باهظا جدا في الحرب لكن
لا مفر امامنا الا ان نواصل القتال قواتنا
قضت حتى الان على الاف المخربين نواصل بكل
قوتنا حتى النهايه والنصر لنستكمل تحقيق
كل اهدافنا بالقضاء على حماس واعاده
مختطفين وضمان ان تشكل غزه اي تهديد لدوله
اسرائيل كما تطرق نتنياهو في كلمته الى
محادثاته الهاتفيه او محادثته الهاتفيه
الليله الماضيه مع الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وقال ان الولايات المتحده تتفهم ان
اسرائيل ماضيه في الحرب حتى تحقيق اهدافها
من دون تحديد سقف زمني
لذلك بالامس تواصلت مجددا مع الرئيس بايدن
اقدر جدا الموقف الصلب للولايات المتحده
في مجلس الامن موقف يدعم جهدنا الحربي قلت
للرئيس بايدن اننا سنحارب حتى الانتصار
المطلق وليستر كل الوقت الذي يتطلبه ذلك
الولايات المتحده تتفهم هذا الامر رايت
تقارير خاطئه تدعي ان الولايات المتحده
منعت او تمنعنا من القيام بعمليات عسكريه
في المنطقه هذا غير صحيح اسرائيل دوله
سياديه وقراراتنا في الحرب تستند الى
اعتبارات عسكريه نحن من
يحددها